but I think the cryptocurrency thing is
an interesting
approach to
reducing the
um
error in the
the database that is called money
um
you know I think I have a pretty deep
understanding of the of what money
actually is on a practical day-to-day
basis because of PayPal
um
you know we really
gotten deep there
um
and right now the money system actually
for practical purposes is is really a
bunch of uh heterogeneous uh mainframes
running uh old Coble
okay you mean literally that's literally
that is literally what's happening in
batch mode
okay in patch mode yeah uh putty the
poor fast as you have to maintain that
code okay that's a that's a pain that's
pain not even fortrans Cobalt yep it's
COBOL expect and they saw the banks were
still buying mainframes in 2021 and
running ancient couple code
uh and uh
you know the the Federal Reserve is like
probably even older than the what the
banks have and they have an old Cobalt
Mainframe
and so now that and and so the the
government effectively has editing
privileges on the on the money database
and they use those editing privileges to
um make more money whenever they want
and this increases the error in the
database that is money so if I think
money should really be viewed through
the lens of information Theory
and uh and so it's uh you're kind of
like uh like an internet connection like
what's the bandwidth uh you know total
bit rate uh what is the latency Jitter
uh packet drop uh you know errors and
errors in the network uh communication
she'll think of money like that
basically
um I think that's probably what I really
think of it and and then say what what
system
uh from an information Theory standpoint
allows an economy to function the best
uh and
you know
um crypto is an attempt to reduce the
the error uh in
uh in money that is contributed by uh
governments uh diluting the money supply
as basically a pernicious pernicious
form of Taxation
so both policy in terms of with
inflation and actual like technological
Cobalt like cryptocurrency takes us into
the 21st century in terms of the actual
systems that allow you to do the
transaction to store wealth all those
kinds of things
foreign
people
um often will think of money as having
power in and of itself
um it does not money is uh is
information and it does not have power
in and of itself
uh like you know again applying the the
physics tools of thinking about things
in the limit is helpful if you are
stranded on a tropical island
um and uh
you have a trillion dollars it's useless
because there's no there's no resource
allocation money is a database for
resource allocation if it's no resource
to allocate accept yourself
so money is useless
um
uh
if you're stranded on desert island with
no food you'd uh all the Bitcoin in the
world
will
not stop you from stopping yeah so
um
so like just just think of money as as a
database for resource allocation
um across time and space
and and then what what what system
uh it is what what in what form should
that that
database what data system
what what would be most effective now
there's a there is a fundamental issue
with
um say Bitcoin in its current form
uh in that it's the transaction volume
is very limited
um and uh the latency this is the
latency for for a properly confirmed
transaction is to is too long much
longer than you'd like
so it's not it's actually not great from
um transaction volume standpoint or
latency standpoint
um
uh so it is perhaps useful as
to so to solve an aspect of the money
database problem uh
which is this sort of store of wealth or
an accounting of relative obligations I
suppose
um but it is not useful as a currency as
a day-to-day currency but people have
proposed different technological
solutions yeah Landing Network and the
layer two technologies on top of that I
mean it's it's all it seems to be all
kind of a trade-off but the point is
it's kind of brilliant to say that just
think about it information think about
what kind of database what kind of
infrastructure enables yeah like you're
operating an economy
um and you need to have some thing that
it allows for the efficient to to have
efficient uh value ratios between
products and services so you've got this
massive number of products and services
and you need to you can't just barter
it's just like that would be extremely
unwieldy uh so you need something that
gives you the the a
a ratio of exchange between goods and
services
um and and then something that allows
you to uh shift obligations across time
like debt debt and Equity shift
obligations across time